Lex Megatrends.
The Crypto Revolution.
Anarchy has not conquered the
UK despite the predictions
of the Sex Pistols.
But a version of it is gaining
traction in finance worldwide.
Cryptocurrencies such as
Bitcoin have bedazzled investors
and are entering the
financial mainstream.
Cryptos embody a core
tenet of anarchism,
co-operation in the absence
of centralised authority.
The financial
establishment is worried.
In this video we predict
where it may all end.
The invention of
Bitcoin in the noughties
is credited to the
pseudonymous Satoshi Nakamoto.
He, or perhaps they, had
the revolutionary idea
of creating a
decentralised currency.
Bitcoin deals are recorded
in a public distributed
ledger, a database
accessed and managed
by multiple participants.
They verify transactions by
solving cryptographic puzzles
and are paid in Bitcoin.
But Bitcoin is a
flagship with flaws.
Criminals favour the currency,
which sometimes resembles
a Ponzi scheme.
It is polluting.
It is volatile.
And Bitcoin is too
clumsy to be handy
for everyday transactions.
Despite this, Bitcoin has done
something truly remarkable.
It has shown that a
decentralised digital currency
can suck in billions, thanks
to healthy dissent, base
greed, lofty idealism, and
sheer fear of missing out.
It was valued at over $1tn
in late October, 2021.
The crypto universe was
valued at some $2.4tn.
That compares with
the UK GDP of $2.7tn.
Lex is still sceptical
about Bitcoin's value.
We don't like European bank
stocks, or Brussels sprouts,
either.
But we believe digital
assets will disrupt finance.
Central banks fret
that cryptos could
destabilise financial systems.
Bitcoin is 12
times more volatile
than the S&P 500 index.
A prolonged bear market
could bring it down to earth
with a bump.
That would hurt
leveraged investors most.
Stablecoins pegged to
official currencies
would increase, rather
than dampen risks,
if assets and liabilities
were mismatched.
Official currencies help
governments stay in charge,
alongside police and armies.
Establishments fear cryptos will
undermine their power, as well
as financial stability.
That is why China has
launched a digital yuan
for retail transactions.
The European Union plans to
introduce a digital euro.
Europeans could end up
depositing some of their cash
with the ECB, or
national central banks,
such as the German Bundesbank.
Central bankers are too
high and mighty to service
retail customers.
Commercial banks would do
that for them, somehow.
Digital euros or
dollars or pounds
wouldn't generate easy
profits for banks, though.
Funding costs would go up
if their own deposits fell.
In a crisis customers
might leave them in droves.
Digital assets create
opportunities for banks, too.
Many are hiring teams
of crypto experts
to advise clients and their
own senior management.
Official regulation
of digital assets
will make their jobs easier.
Eventually low-friction
dealing in stocks and bonds,
using public ledger technology,
will hit profits for some
but raise it for others.
Lex believes the financial
establishment will struggle
to assimilate digital assets.
But assimilate them it will.
Some cryptos will stay
forever on the margins.
But anarchism in finance,
as in politics and music,
is very vulnerable to sell-outs.
As crypto bros take jobs in
the City and on Wall Street
the idealists may
ask one another
the question posed by Johnny
Rotten of the Sex Pistols:
"Ever get the feeling
you've been cheated?"